Let's uh welcome uh Rajiv and India uh
to uh Pi data Seattle today
uh they're they are both um machine
learning platform engineers at Lyft
um so uh they'll be telling us about
building uh machine learning
observability pipelines so let's give uh
Rajiv prabhakar and in India Round of
Applause and have them get started thank
you
good luck y'all
thank you everyone can you hear me well
myself on indoor and here's Rajiv
I know it's just after lunch time so you
had many options to go with your friends
to visit the lake or hang out but still
you decided to come to this talk so
thank you for that I really appreciate
that we really appreciate that
okay so we will today it's a Hands-On
Workshop so we have um we have the
slides here and if you can go to this
repo
we we have the codes for that repo here
and there is a shared dock I don't I'm
not sure how to share this but this is
the repo where you have everything for
this today's code
so once you take a snapshot of this
I can quickly start
it's a 90 minutes Workshop so
we we do not have a visibility like
what's the machine configuration of each
of you has so in the readme I will I
mentioned like what kind of
configuration we are expecting as a
Docker desktop
but even if you do not have it don't
fret just listen to the principle and
the fundamental workings around it you
can try it at home after after this talk
or when you have time later
but specifically we are looking for a
Docker desktop which is around at least
four four to six CPUs
and you have at least 32 gigs of RAM on
the docker desktop and if you can bring
up that I will show you live how to do
it
and it's also on the pi data conference
uh
abstract the link is also there
for the GitHub repo okay
so let's start here
so you we already got introduced and so
we will talk about the agenda first so
here we will say why did we need to
build an anomaly detection system
at our company
and what are the challenges because the
data is at scale so so we can work with
pandas data frame on notebooks but how
can we scale it up so we will talk about
the pain points and what did we do
to mitigate those pain points and what
are the solutions we used
and the second demo would be like using
statistical packages such as stats
forecast
and we will specifically Deep dive into
the algorithm that we use and some of
the tweaks we make
to make anomaly detection at scale
and the third part will be a little
maybe two to three minutes talk like
what we learned along the way
we will try to keep it simple and short
so that everyone can follow
and we'll have questions and answers in
between as well and you can also ask
like at the end of The Talk
so here are the resources again
we also released two blogs about what we
are talking today
uh once we share these slides this will
be available to you
okay so let's talk about the problem
so in general in any uh
ml platform in any company which uses ml
platform you will get so many models
deployed and many inference requests are
millions and hundreds we have like
billions of requests coming across many
models even if we make a one ride
request there will be 10 models at least
working on it so think about like
millions of rides
so we we capture all those inference
requests essentially we are
instrumenting the instruments request
and logging into some kind of database
in the back end it can be some SQL DB or
high FDB Hive database
but the problem is
not all models get the same number of
requests some models are very popular
some models they they are not that
popular some models get requests more in
the peak time in the day some models get
more request during the night or the
evening it depends and the second
problem is not all models have the same
kind of features some models have
numerical more numerical features less
categorical some of some has just the
reverse and some models have maybe have
10 features some has 30 features we just
cannot know as a platform platform
engineer
so what can we do what can we do about
that so since the requests since all the
inference requests are so wide and so
varied we do not have a uniform way of
processing them how can we glean out
Matrix or statistics out of them in a
more uniform manner because the number
of features is not fixed the num feature
types is not fixed we do not know the
feature names the amount of requests or
the amount of data coming in is also not
same sum has like a maybe 10 GB of data
coming in in one day some may have like
one GB of data coming in one day and
even the hourly patterns are different
and there is seasonality in this model
predictions inference request as well so
how can we mitigate that so our today's
talk is about that given this so variety
of large number of models and this
models keeps on growing is there a
unified approach of tackling this
problem or there is a simple is there a
simpler solution
so the solution we you used is y logs
we we we investigated couple of Open
Source as well as proprietary products
for model monitoring but we think we
felt that y logs fit our bill perfectly
ah there is a diagram here schematic
diagram think about it in real life what
it happens like we have model raw logs
or inference logs coming in every day
day one day to for model one and model
two and so if we could
uh profile this data what does profiling
means profiling means you take a
snapshot of the features coming in what
is that feature what is the snapshot the
snapshot will contain the mean the
standard deviation mean uh minimum value
maximum value cardinality of the
features and the data keeps on coming
and we cannot just sit and wait like I
process it one day and the next day also
there will be like lots of thousands of
data is coming so how can I process them
incrementally it's not that it is fixed
it's every day it is growing in size
so we we investigated ylocks and we
found that first of all it is open
source from ylabs and second thing is a
while while logs gives a feature that
you can take any any features or any
predictions it may have n number of
features numerical x x numerical y
categorical feature you still can
profile all of this data and create a
binary out of it and what does this
binary has this binary is nothing but
the profile of the data or the snapshot
or the statistics of the underlying data
I need to be clear when we have a real
example
and the second point is
even if we profile it today we need to
again do that so every day I am getting
a data how can I get a profile for the
entire month should I wait till the end
of the month and process the entire data
to get the monthly profile or is there a
way I can profile every day
and I keep on joining merging the
profiles every day to create an overall
profile at the end of the month or every
day I keep on updating that profile so
that I don't have to do a lot of work at
the end of the month at the end of the
month is still one day's job but I merge
all the previous profiles while logs
gives that benefit and it supports Park
as a back-end engine and you also you
use Fugue which is open source
abstraction layer on a on compute engine
it can support spark Ray or any other
compute engine
and Fugue helps us to abstract this
profiling mechanism using Y logs so it
will be clear in a demo
so now we will go into the demo straight
away
before I go into the demo uh is there
any question I can answer
so to start the demo once you go to this
GitHub repo it is very simple
straightforward we have a Docker image
everything is inbuilt into that Docker
image
so you can open your
favorite terminal
just like I'm doing now let me know if
the fonts are clear
or if the fonts is fonts are legible
so we will run this Docker image
it is a publicly available Docker image
so anyone can use it
so while the docker image is coming up
so let's go here
and open the jupyter notebook terminal
and there will have our entire demo
by the way all the codes are coming from
the GitHub there is nothing like
here which is not in GitHub
so we will first show you so it will be
divided into Parts as I mentioned in the
beginning so we will have one notebook
for distributed profiling and the second
notebook for actually using the
statistical packages
so if you see in the notebook in the
docker there are two files named the
same
what is this for so I will be using this
demo which is like all the cells are
empty just in case anything happens with
live demo and demo gods are not in favor
I can revert back to this cell where
everything is already executed and you
know the output beforehand
all right
so
we will
okay I will minimize this window
try to minimize okay
oh okay cool
okay so some customary housekeeping job
seabon and pandas so now I will this is
a kind of a real data that is taken from
of one of our logs of of course features
names have been changed for security
purposes and
um and yeah and we have like massage the
data a little bit but but the bottom
line is let's assume how does a real
data would look like
so this is a model data so inference
request came at this point of time and
this is the name of the model and look
at the requests it's like a Json
structure a simple Json because we don't
know the number of features we don't
know the cat we don't know the type so
we purchase everything as jsons it may
be 100 features it may be 20 features it
may be 1000 features it doesn't matter
everything is just a Json
so once you have those jsons
so these are like the values of those
features of course the features have
been like obfuscated here
so we get the data from The Hive table
or let's say we have a local S3 bucket
now we want to extract this feature
because these jsons are not valuable I
mean jsons are valuable for storing but
for processing and profiling I cannot
work we cannot work with the Json so we
need to extract the features so how can
we do that we we take that column and
then we do a pandas data frame Json
loads as simple as that and if we do
that so we make a small function that
given a big data frame can I process
individual rows and pick out the
features
so I will execute this cell while I I
speak so the I'm trying we are trying to
say can you think before going to scale
or big data can you think of ways or
your your tune your thought process in a
manner that can I break down my problem
into the most unit operation which is
independent of each other
so in this case one row processing is
the most unit operation and if I can
make it work for one row I can make it
work for million rows
so the the the the the the
responsibility of making it work on
million rows is the duty of the
computation framework not mine my job is
to make it work on one row so that's
what we are doing we are loading each
feature and then if we transform it we
will get something like this so all the
features have been transformed because
there are like six six features in this
Json so feature five six so they are
arranged in a haphazard manner but when
we transform it we get this feature so
now what we do we have features but we
also need some other data as well so we
check we concat with the original data
demo demo DF and then now we get a very
holistic picture that this is my model
this was my Json and these are the
features I had
of course I don't have column names here
I will fix it in the next method so
the goal I we designed this notebook is
I will show you what we are doing each
individual piece and then Mark take all
individual piece and put it into a
function a unit of work
so this is what this is called it is a
unit function to work on a partition
data so let us assume that your data is
too big to fit on one machine even it it
cannot fit on like 10 machines you will
have many executors or process can you
write one function
that will take each row even it is
distributed in many machine each row and
convert it into my features and the
model
so when we put everything here so you
see that I have actually copied pasted
what I have showed right now I have
copied pasted Json loads and I have
pasted the sorted things like that in
addition to that I have added some more
extra fee model features ah model
variables and then I have done the same
concatenation again so I did not do
anything which is not I showed you
before but I just
made it like one function
and if I can
run this method extract features and I
pass the entire data frame I should be
getting it for all the rows in the data
frame
so while it is running
ah so let me uh
let me let me wait for the results to
come back
so if you see that since this data frame
was around like 300 000 records I
processed it like within like uh 15
seconds live in this in this demo
so now this data frame has all the
necessary stuff extracted out
and I already have my unit
function to make it work
and let's see how many dates I have I
have around 88 days of data and how many
hours of course 0 to 23.
and let's say can I can I take
one one day worth of data and do
profiling so now I finished the feature
engineering step or feature processing
step I will go to profiling step I will
pause here because that's the next
Junction and we need to be very very
attentive to that is there any questions
around it so we just did our homework
make things ready for the next
big process
okay so they to give a glimpse or I we
took a data for uh 10th of February and
our five and see there are many rows and
I only took head five what does it mean
it means that even in one hour I can
many I can have many points even in one
day one hour I can have many points
because one hour has 3600 seconds I can
have data per seconds so I I can have at
least 3600 if I have data coming in per
milliseconds imagine I can have 10 000
records every one hour on a given day
for a given model
and think about if you combine it for
all days all hours all models how big
that data can be
okay so now we go to the next step
what's the next step so we need to
profile what what is a profile profile
is generating statistics
while I talk I will execute this lines
oh okay this is quite fast okay so we
use y logs and I'll give you an example
I took a February data frame
on a particular date just the one I
showed you
and I use y log to make a profile of
that data similarly I took a competing
data frame from the next month March
exactly one month later 10th March
exactly one same hour
five and I also took that data frame why
I am taking two different data frames to
show that there can be some distribution
drifts
and is it possible to visualize it yes
how will we do that let's look at first
of all let us use y log to profile it so
when we use y log to profile it what is
what's the output so we profile only two
features so there are six features we
only profile two features for the demo
purpose here and what does it show it
shows the distribution
of the only that particular date and
hour what was the distribution of
feature five and minimum and maximum
value and many all the quartile values
similarly we take exactly if after one
month what is the distribution of those
features next month of course it is not
same but how different
so and it will be visibly different if
you see here Max is like 121 here Max is
like
Max is like something 16 000 something
and mean and medians are different of
course data changes over time
so if we visualize it
again using the Y logs visualizer and if
I just take only one feature to
visualize and superimpose this it will
be clear that there is significant
distribution but we are not talking
about distribution drift today
I'm just highlighting it here to say
that data changes over time and creating
the profiles every day and merging it or
overlapping it we can quickly identify
things and this is the basic principle
or premise we will use so so now we have
like y logs profile
but this y loss profile is a kind of a
different data type is kind of a data
set profile view how can I use it so in
order to use it and to incrementally
process profiles day by day day by day
and merge it we need to serialize it so
why logs provides also the serialize
method so that you can convert your
profile into a binary
and if you convert into binary what
happens
you can save it into the database
and load it back later to reprocess
so we we complete the Second Step
profiling of the data to get a
statistical Matrix out of them
so let's pause here and see if you have
any questions on the entire thought
process
yes yes please
so for the features we have a hike table
so we will have another Hive table to
store
these profiles so the question was where
are we going to what kind of database is
it the while logs database or it is our
own database did I get the question
correct
any more questions
so now
I so now I showed like I took only just
one day of worth of data for each month
and profiled it
how can I scale it
now the question comes how to scale it I
have so many days so many models
the trick to do is again the same
principle that I followed think of the
business Logic the unit function the
unit function is to profile
a chunk a partition so we write a
function and whatever I have talked so
far I've just copy paste it and put that
code here that create the profile create
the view and serialize
in one shot
and what is features DF features DF
assume that you have so big data frame
it cannot fit in one machine so I
divided it partition and there are 10
amazing each each partition is this
feature DF each partition on one
executor or node is this chunk can I
profile that chunk this is this method
profile features if I can profile one
chunk I can profile million chunks
and so we write this unit function
here
and then
we test it like OK we wrote the function
can it work is it working how can I test
it I just pass one chunk
one day one chunk and test it out I I
get the profile binary so I am confident
it will work and then I will scale it up
using Fugue so how does Fugue helps me
few helps me this this cell will take
three minutes to run
on my laptop but I will explain
how it works so few has the this
function called transform
what what is it transforming it is
transforming this data
the big data we had using which function
profile features it works on one one
chunk so it can work on many chunks and
how should I divide get my chunks I
should divide the entire data
partitioned by these four things that I
want every day every hour every model
every version
for each of these I want to divide this
data for each of these distinct
combination I want to divide the data
into chunks and I want to profile them
for this chance
so I will take a pause here to to kind
of uh see if you have any doubts or
questions on till this point
loving other
brightness extra minutes
and also crack it and
the more streamlined
I think y logs is more on profiling it
will not interfere or dictate how much
you log how much you not log so that is
the decision we take so for each model
we have a configuration like
we we sample down the number of requests
coming in and then we log it while logs
is just for helping us to process later
not live it's like a post logged
processing so that we can create
profiles later
even just looking
all the magic
makes sense but
because
it takes a while to even this
which features or what I want to love
and to make them straight there is I
don't have space or yeah graduated
messages
all right thank you hon so any more
questions
so while we you are talking the data was
processed and then you can see uh it
process like around 300 000 records
under three minutes
and you can see this binary has been
created assume that we write another
Hive table to store these binaries
so what next
so so now if you see the data frame it's
like day hour every day every hour every
month this model
I have our profiles for each day for
each model and each version
can we can I use it
what's the use can I use it for more
fundamental more more higher level
aggregations because we have already the
hourly profiles can we get the daily
profile if I would have wanted a daily
profile
I could have done it by saying okay can
I re-execute this method just dropping
this hour column it's it's per day now
do I need to redo it again
no
can I use what I have already done yes
how can I do that
so for that we have to use a feature
called merge merger while logs
so let's assume that
we have ah
we already know the February ylocks
profile for the February data frame
chunk
and this is like this let's say the
distribution Max is this or mean is this
and we also know for March
so we can check the distribution Max is
121 And this is one data frame this is
second data frame now
if I want to test is y logs good enough
so what did we do we have two two
profiles and then we call the merge
method
we have two profiles merge it
and we will get a resultant profile what
is the resultant profile so with Max it
is very easy to understand it is one
sixteen thousand something so in the
merge also if that is the maximum value
I should get that Max
so we get that Max here
for one of the features for feature file
similarly it will work
for the other so the profiles are
merging well
I mean profiles are merging I do not
know well or good or bad how can I test
it
so in order to test that
we manually now instead of merging the
profiles we take those two data chunks
and merge it ourselves we are merging
the data chunks now so we are taking the
features DF on 10th of March as well as
10th of February as well as March
and on our five and we concat the data
frames now
and then if we concat those data frames
and then if we run ylocks profile on
those concated data frames do I get the
same statistics
yeah I still do get the same statistic
this the Max and mean are still the same
the medials and mean will will still be
will still be the same if you see the
median here you see the median here it's
still the same what does it show us that
using Y logs on partial profiles and
merging partial profiles is equal to
processing your entire data frame
using ylocks so we don't need to process
your entire data frame we just process
on parts and merge that's it that will
be good enough for us so and how can we
like put everything in use in real life
so we create a function called again the
same principle applies before going to
Big Data or distributed company just
think about
can I can I write a unit work that is
independent of each other
if I can write it for one I can write it
for Millions so we create a function
called profile reduce and I will just
run it for uh for to make it quick what
does this profile reduce do
assume that you are getting hourly
profiles because we have already
profiled our data and it's in Hive and
saved let's say again we have a spark
job which will take these profiles and
partition the data we do not know how it
partition we decide the partitioning key
assume that it was partition
for every model and version and every
day
so every day has 24 hours so at least
there will be like 24 rows and each hour
can have like 1000 rows so at least we
can expect around 30 000 to 40 000 size
per partition
what we do is we we calculate the
resultant feature by using the simple
normal python reduce function but
instead what we do is we already got the
why Lux profile we we profile it we take
the profile binary it's deserializing we
serialized it to save it now we
deserialize it once we deserialize it we
merge every profile is deserialized and
merged
after merging what we do we again
serialize
so profiles were there small small
profiles were there we took it
deserialize each of them merge it
re-serialize and save it to the database
it's the same thing we do for
predictions uh features as well as
predictions and we also definitely we
need to drop the hour because we are
doing a daily profile and things like
that and once we do that we will get the
result like this so here you see date uh
so we have the hourly profile like this
it was the original input data frame
date our model and then when we do
profile reduce onto that data frame the
output is every hour is reduced and I
get just only one one for that day
if I can do it for one day I can do it
for any days
how can I do it for any days just use
few
just to use the profile reduce function
now instead of one chunk I pass the Big
Data frame here
and I do not need hour and just divide
partition your entire data frame based
on DS model and version so every profile
is now being
deserialized reduced merged serialized
and persisted to
to the database so this is how where I
will stop and this is the end of the
first part of the demo so that we are
using ylocks for profiling we are first
of all we did feature engineering then
we did profiling and then we learned
about serialization and deserialization
and after using all of these together
now we can also merge and Aggregate and
create higher level profiles of these
now these output is the basis of the
next demo which is like the more the
statistical part
so I will pause here and see if there
are questions while it is running
it should take a one minute to finish
yeah
I had a question
so what is the profile providing to Lyft
in this case is it just for checking for
anomalies in model drift or is that what
the next section is about yeah so the
the profiling is helping is first of all
first of all it's a distributed way of
getting the statistics because I I can
keep on process we can keep on
processing small chunks of data
and keep on incrementally merging it so
every day we are processing only one
day's worth of data and since we already
have the profile for the previous days
we can just keep on merging it so it
helps a lot with the distributed
processing and incremental processing we
don't have to like sit on their spin up
huge machines to cross one month of
worth of data it's not needed y logs is
very fast it uses a pi bind under the
hood by and going through these profiles
and coming back serializing and
designing they use protobuf as well so
it is very fast it is cost effective and
it is it runs in very as you can see I'm
I'm processing 300 records on a Docker
machine under 300 000 records on a
Docker machine on my laptop and live so
think about it how it works in real life
the second thing is
these profiles are itself now has become
like time series like every hour this is
my profile or every day this is my
profile now these profiles have become
time series now I can do drift on this
time series if this was my profile last
month this is my profile this month what
is the drift between this I can keep on
doing the drift every month so I don't
have to like come recompute everything
what happened last month and this month
compared drift no the data is already
there I just need to calculate the drift
I can also calculate drift by hour last
hour this was my profile this hour this
is my profile what's the drift because I
showed you uh drift example here ah in
the here we can also forecast like if
this is the mean profile or mean value
of a feature last hour
uh or it was like last seven hours can I
train a model on this mean and forecast
what should be the mean value in the
next seven hours so when live data comes
can I compare with the projected mean
and say it's an anomaly so that's the
second part we will come but essentially
to put so y-logs gives us a uniform way
of processing weird a variety of things
and the resultant profiles itself is a
Time series which can be leveraged for
other things
okay so we yeah
oh yeah sorry
amazing
um how effectively does the merge work
and is it just merging on the statistics
themselves or is there additional
metadata written in the serialized form
that's being used to assist with the
merges
and even worse
all right if there are no more questions
I will give it to Rajiv he will talk
about the stats forecast application on
this same data
can you talk hello okay
thank you onindo
um
thank you all for coming
so so far we learned about building
profiles for the first 40 minutes right
now
um I wanted to start off before I go
ahead and execute code on this notebook
that everybody can do I want to
understand what did you all of you get
out of profile so like I want to
understand what is the difference
between sampling and profiling can
anybody tell me what is the difference
between sampling and profiling
and why why would we choose profiling
versus sampling
sure I mean so you're talking about
having profiles built on top of samples
that is corrected right yeah so one of
the drawbacks of sampling is we miss
some of the key metrics so for example
in anomaly detection one of the key
things we are looking for is finding the
one-off thing that we want to catch
right samplings more often than not
tends to have
um we we basically will miss this one
off anomalies so with profiling what
happens is
um
we essentially go through shift through
all the logs or data that is given and
we capture all these rare events and
build these profiles
um it's not like it's it's a common
practice across industry to do sampling
and then take a mean or median or
standard deviation and do anomaly
detection that's that's not knowing
that's not new but the approach we have
taken is to do anomaly detection on
profiles because profiles as an Indo
mentioned in the previous uh previous
talk they capture they are easy to
maintain they are mergeable they are
computationally incrementally only so
you basically compute profiles only once
a day or once an hour and then you can
go ahead and merge them to get like
higher granularity profiles building low
granularity profiles so computationally
it's much less expensive so for example
if we basically build a huge like let's
say we build a mean for a big data set
and then four days later we decide that
we want to have the median or we want to
have something else computationally
becomes really expensive so profiles
also help with that so you have low i o
bound problems computationally less less
lower bound problems so but one of the
key things is between sampling and
profiling I want to take away here is
profiling captures rare events which is
one of the key things for anomaly
detection we want to capture as many
rare events as possible at that which
profiling helps us to do and also we
want to do it in a way which is
economical right like
theoretically we can have many solutions
but practically we're all constrained
with compute costs and all those things
so we want to have an approach which is
scalable and also have a way with to
capture all of them as much as possible
so having said that let me go back to
this slide
quickly
[Music]
um
all right
okay so in this uh in this talk for the
next few minutes we're going to talk
about anomaly detection using the build
profiles from the last talk
um so we are going to basically focus on
using time series forecasting so we are
going to use uh time series forecasting
univariate time series forecasting uh
for doing anomaly detection there are
various packages out there in fact like
uh before we are going to use nextella
stats forecast package for doing time
series forecasting before that we
actually even used Facebook profit we
also tried with linkedin's gray kite but
we actually decided to stick with stats
forecast because of because of its
really good performance as well as a
wide range of options in terms of the
model selections that you have like it
basically provides
mstl Auto arima exponential smoothing
ETFs and name it and all of them are
neatly wrapped behind an interface so if
anybody wants to change the way they do
anomaly detection on different models
it's just a flip of a model without any
change in code so maintenance is really
easy it's really fast they actually use
number and panel Computing behind the
scenes to make it really fast so um so
for these reasons we kind of chose we
kind of stuck with
stress forecast
okay so once we uh so the next step in
an oblique Direction once we do
forecasting in the in a univariate uh
for clustering is we actually have
confidence intervals uh confidence
intervals gives you the bounds of so in
forecasting forecasting gives you a
value once the value is there it also
gives you a confidence interval which
says how confident this is
um if we Define an anomaly as anything
that is outside the confidence interval
that's essentially what we do
so the graph here is an example of ah
what we'll see in the uh tutorial uh in
the next few minutes uh it basically so
the the blue line is the prediction
value of a model it's actually is the
mean of the prediction value of a model
and the red lines are the highlighted
anomalies ah by uh by by the stats by
what we do
um okay so once this is done anomaly
detection right like okay we found
anomalies great what next
um seldom this is not that useful like
okay we say that there is an anomalinear
model
okay they acknowledge that but the
harder problem is why is there an
anomaly what can we do about it can we
actually try to give some more context
around why the anomalies existed so
there are many reasons why anomalies can
happen in this particular uh tutorial
we're going to focus on feature drift
like we're going to try to understand
how a change in feature
impacts a change in prediction
um for that we basically try to fit a
Model A simple regression model
and then try to explain how that model
behaves with shape shapely values we're
going to go through all these things in
the tutorial okay
I want to pass here and then ask any
question anybody has any questions so
far
um
yeah
cool
um let's go with the demo
okay so the first part is we basically
read the
daily profile so the daily profile was
generated from
oh sorry thank you
is the size okay
okay
the first part is we basically load the
daily profile we generated from the
previous talk and then from then on we
go ahead and Define the detector so I
want to pause here and take a minute to
explain what this is
so once the profiles are loaded what do
we do what metric do we choose to do
anomaly detection on so it really
depends on what we are interested in
like some models have prediction as like
like numeric numeric predictions some
have categorical predictions
um we have had situations where
um suddenly there is a new categorical
prediction value coming out we have had
situations numerical predictions are
largely uh largely the use case for us
too so the first step is to choose what
distribution metric that we use to
choose to find anomalies on so for this
ah particular demo we are going to use
uh mean of the mean of the predictions
as a as a metric
um I will go ahead and I'll talk about
what is an msteel detector so if you
basically if you are following this
tutorial there is a file called ad demo
this has all the definitions uh I I'll
go I'll come to that in a minute
um but I just want to basically point
out that we're going to choose mean of
the predictions as the unit of reporting
anomalies on
so in this particular demo specifically
we have only one model in reality these
models as aninder was pointing we are
basically collecting logs from all the
models in a centralized Place coming
through Kafka or streaming and then
collecting through logs and then we sift
through them and build profiles there
are like various various models in
reality but for this purpose for for
this demo purpose we're going to have
only one model so in this we are
basically seeing that we have a model
called demo model the version date the
dates are like basically daily profiles
because it's a daily profile you can see
the each each line corresponds to one
day of profile so we have the
predictions and the feature profile for
um for each of these and then we have
the total number of Records roughly
sample in each of these
so the next step
the next step after ah we decide on what
what metric to pick on is to extract
these profiles so like you saw about you
saw about these things in the in the
last talk so these are the different
metrics we have the pretz DF basically
tells us the predictions DFS
metrics all the so you have a Time
series of different metrics we have
cardinality counts Max men and all the
distribution profiles like mean medium
standard deviation things like that and
as as I said before we are going to we
are going to pick the mean for the stock
ah and then if you look at the features
TF the features DF is represented a
little bit differently so I'll go back
to extract I'll go back to this function
which is essentially the extract
profiles to see what's going on so
before I go there so the features DF
which is all these uh each of these
features has uh you are univariate
distribution mean values uh for every
single day so we just decided to pick
the mean values for every single feature
for this uh for this demo so like if you
look at this function here extract
profiles it's a pretty simple function
we basically take the the the daily
profile created we go through we go
through those profiles we go through the
features profile and predictions profile
for every single day and we and for
features we capture the mean of them and
for predictions we capture all of them
because the reason we capture all of
them is because
um it it can become so if I go back here
at the very top ah you see here we
basically Define detector with mean I
can for example also if I'm not happy
with this or if I want to have a more
things I can also say something like
distribution stash median right so it
gives us the flexibility to do anomaly
detection on more than one metric and we
need not do mstl detector we can even
have I don't know uh Auto arima
if if we have that available so it gives
us the flexibility to choose different
models and different uh metrics on on a
Model basis
and that's the reason we kind of ah kept
all the statistical values for each of
the predictions
so
um so once this is done we essentially
extract it out and return the
predictions on the features TF
um
yeah that's that's pretty much about uh
the the extraction of the profiles I
wanted to pause here a little bit before
the next step because the next step is
about generating the forecasts and how
we do things
do we have any questions at this point
okay cool okay so once we have this
profiles the next step is actually to
generate the forecasts so I'm going to
examine one detector so in this in this
demo I have just defined one detector uh
which is basically the mstl detector and
the using the mean so we're going to
extract one particular uh we're going to
run this function it's going to take
probably 50 to 50 seconds or something
while this is running I would like to go
and look at what the score mean how do
we actually do this right a detector is
basically the an mstl detector so if
let's look at this mstl detector class
so the detector class is a wrapper
around the stats forecast uh that that
I've written written it basically we
need to specify a few things for stats
forecast
one is being what models do we want to
use for anomalytraction in this
particular case we are only going to use
mstl
we are going to tell them what metric on
the data frame column that we're going
to pass to use in this case we're going
to use distribution mean and the level
is basically the confidence level we
want to basically ask what confidence
level that the status forecast package
should report for the confidence bounds
so we're going to initialize this with
this and once we call the score function
the score function basically uh is uh is
is a caller is basically does the actual
Computing of the forecasts so what it
does is essentially takes the data frame
which is our entire data set and then it
takes the models and frequency frequency
is basically either day it's it's the
daily frequency hourly frequency and
things like that so we basically Define
the frequency of this models we
initialize stats forecast here and then
stats forecast basically we use this
function called forecast
in forecast we basically specify the
Horizon
um and also one thing yeah so we
basically specify the Horizon of of the
forecast here
fitted one unique thing that we really
liked is turning fitted equal to True ah
inside stats forecast like the interface
gives us in sample in Sample values for
the predictions and confidence intervals
like this is really really useful
because let's say we are going on
working on a month or two months old of
data and we are forecasting for the next
two days
turning fitted equal to True basically
gives us in Sample predict in Sample
values for forecast and confidence level
for all the previous two months so we
can go back in history and then
basically try to find out where were the
anomalies and how to report anomalies on
so this is this is one of the cool cool
things that uh that is done there
um one thing I wanted to mention is also
the seasonality so
um I'm using mstl here which is multiple
seasonality Trend lowers so the season
it supports multiple seasonalities so
for example let's say you have a daily
seasonality weekly seasonality and
monthly seasonality so you can specify
an array of seasonalities and then the
model actually takes it in uh and and
then and then just computes it
um any model you you take is basically
wrapped around this score function
because the the core or the fundamental
way to compute for for forecasting is
just this function ah just this simple
function
um I'll go back to this and we'll see
what the forecasting came looks like
um
so here are the days the DS represents
the dates uh for each of the days we
basically have y the Y's are our actual
predictions so these predictions
remember are the distribution mean
values for uh for for this model mstl
represents the the forecasted value from
the stats forecast package MST are low
and mstl high these are the confidence
bonds so if you look at the top we
basically specified our confidence bound
as
99.9 so you can even basically go as an
array and say like you can have multiple
confidence bounds so so you can you you
can try out multiple things at the same
time and the beauty of this is it
doesn't take any extra noticeable time
so they have written it so well that it
leverages parallel Computing and number
really well so um
adding more seasonality more number of
ah confidence bounds doesn't take any
extra time
yeah so
I would want to pause here and check if
everybody are with me have any questions
on
stats forecast or
um why we chose it or anything else
okay cool let's move on
so once we Define these anomalies uh
sorry once we Define this forecasted
data we are going to uh we're going to
try to find anomalies so as I said
anomalies are anything where we say that
if the
if the confidence
um basically if if the prediction is not
lying within the confidence bounds we
Define that as an anomaly ah in this
particular case we are not going to use
the uh the forecasted value for the next
two days
um I can talk about after this
presentation if you have time I'm going
to I can talk about like how we are we
have a few couple of projects we have
lined up how we are trying to use it for
real-time anomaly detection and stuff
um
OK so let's run this so basically after
running this we basically found that uh
we scored we scored it and we try to
find the anomalies and it said that for
the mean there are two ah two anomalies
or at two different discrete times
um I want to pause here a little bit and
talk about Fugue
um and why it matters so far because
this is only a single model
um demo a demo situation with a single
model everything is running fine and
things are okay now if we want to in
practice practically uh it's not going
to be a single model it's going to be
multiple models uh and and lots and lots
of data so what we can do is basically
we can leverage Fugue a few basically
what Fugue basically takes in our daily
profile and we can Define this function
called Fugue find anomalies so few find
anomalies is a simple function of what
we just went through like we basically
extract the profiles for each of the
detectors we find the anomalies and
return a data frame with the model name
and and the anomalies so it is a simple
function this function as you can see is
very pandas it is very testable
um
and and
and basically we can use this function
in Fugue to find to do a distributed
computing across multiple models so if
you look at it so we basically defined
the daily profile we use the find
anomalies function we defined we are
going to pass in the detectors that we
defined at the beginning of this
function and we are going to define the
schema output schema which is the model
name as well as what is the other thing
which is the anomalies per model name
and we are going to partition the data
by model name in this case model name is
unique enough where so each model name
data will go to one partition we are
going to sort it by date and I'm saying
we are going to use engine as task but
if we we can we can even say engine has
none which will basically uh you use
pandas we can say engine as spark if we
want to use spark we can use engine as
Ray the beauty of this is all of these
run without the user requiring any
explicit changes uh thinking in terms of
Ray or spark or anything all the user
does is Define the function in terms of
pandas how they understand in a single
machine kind of a scenario and once it
is done the choose a write partition
scheme and then choose your right up
engine and then run it so and then like
so for example if I say engine as none
ah I do not need this config and I can
run this
um it's basically going to give the same
same result it's going to take some time
and it's going to give the same result
so this like to be to be real and as few
has been a really uh Big Game Changer
across the company for us because
um not many people understand this how
distributed computing works and probably
not many people would want to
yeah
yeah yeah
so like Fugue is really good like we can
talk about few uh later too
um
okay so once we ah now that we basically
found the anomalies ah let's look at how
to see those anomalies as we saw in the
presentation this is how the anomalies
look like
um
we basically the Blue Line represents
the mean of the predictions and the red
lines part the anomalies for the two
different time stamps we found now that
we found this anomalies now what do we
do next like
um how do we how do we analyze what
features or what features cause this
issue
um
can anybody tell me like have any any
thoughts about this like what would you
do to analyze which features
um
causes prediction impact what what would
you do
what's that a sharp analysis
yeah yeah exactly so we we do sharp
analysis but in order to do sharp
analysis uh what we do is we want to
essentially measure the change in
prediction with respect to change in
features so essentially our Dy is going
to be the change in predictions and our
DX is going to be the change in features
so like if you look at this function ah
we Define our X as the features our y as
the predictions and what we want to do
is we are going to train a regressor
saying we want to fit a model where we
try to find the change in features with
respect to the change in predictions
so this basically this model we take
this model and then use sharp to explain
what this looks like what the output of
this model essentially what it gives us
is the change in features impact to the
change in predictions because in a
stable ml system right like if you if
you go to this diagram with this this
blue line we day over day the mean value
of predictions should not drift as much
they should they will definitely change
but they are not going to jump
drastically what we are trying to
measure is the draft drastic drift in
this uh prediction day over day and we
want to measure the DraStic change with
respect to change in features so doing
this uh doing this model training was uh
is how we do so let's look at what
happens if you do that we basically use
a bar chart so what this bar chart tells
us is essentially in this case feature
five the change in feature five has the
highest impact to the change in
predictions
so this is something which we are
looking to reason out right like we want
to understand which features change
because made you made a prediction
change at the same time so in this case
we basically found feature five has the
highest impact in terms of the
prediction output and other features
follow
now that we know that information
we basically um try to find how the
features look like at the same time in
the same importance so if you look at
this feature Phi at the same time had
the highest like clearly had a big
impact and and also at the same time on
the other side of the time frame also
there was a big drop which had a big
impact on the model prediction feature
six at the same time had a similar
attribution here
feature three not so much but the model
thought that this is a change in this
was relevant feature one and again
feature two ah so like this this whole
feature uh importance is based on the
importance what we got from the sharp
values
so this kind of comes to the end of what
my demo but
um
the the
takeaway for this anomaly detection is
doing anomaly detection on mean or
standard deviation is not anything new
but
using profiles to do the same thing and
ability to reason out why there was an
anomaly detection why there was an
anomaly on features
um like has saved like many many hours
for across many people many teams
because most of the time when there's an
anomaly people try to scramble not many
models don't get monitored on a daily
basis features add-in features drift
over time but ability to reason out
quickly and pinpoint so that you can
take corrective actions within time has
saved us lots and lots of times and also
one thing I wanted to say is like we do
automated anomaly detection as in when
in reality like every day there are
models being written by various teams
across the company we can't have users
go and onboard every single model to an
anomaly detection system so we have the
centralized way where all the logs come
in they get profile and automatically
get picked up and then this this anomaly
detection system runs we generate the
graphs and and
alerts can go off to users based on
based on various uh settings the users
have chosen
with this I would like to stop and any
questions
yeah
sorry yeah
sure
sorry can you repeat
um
what would so the question is what would
we do if we have to do collinearity on
the features
um that's a good question uh
community
I mean the methodology
but as long as it works like in general
I think
yeah
like the the idea is to provide solution
generically for now because having
specific Solutions can be very expensive
uh wow
yeah sorry uh
what did I just go
sorry I can't come now what do you say
how do we so the question is how do we
suppress
oh
I don't know what happened
um okay so the question is how do we
suppress duplicates and alerts
how do how do we find uh duplicates and
so basically you're trying to find out
how do we handle false positives and all
those kinds of things yeah so one thing
is we choosing good confidence bounds so
having a 95 percentile confidence bound
is can be very noisy
um we based on trial we have like we
basically tried out different algorithms
like mstl autoarima with different uh
univariate like mean standard deviation
and things like that
we basically have
fine-tuned that like based on like trial
and error we have found out that this is
the mean with mstl and autoimmer works
best for us
um and if
if something feels that this is alerting
them way too much and creating uh alert
alert fatigue we can we plan to actually
give them the ability to pick a
different confidence level or a
different algorithm also but for now
with this we have had reasonable success
where we are not alerting way too much
uh with with 99. like three nines we
don't actually have lot of false
positives for our use case but again it
depends from Case by case basis
um yeah
that's that doesn't answer roughly yeah
yes
you find yourself just referring to the
profiles or do you get specific
questions
thank you thanks for the question so
I'll repeat the question for everybody
so the question was
with profiles do we have to go back to
the data for specific models for
specific things or does it capture
everything so the answer is we do not
have to go back the whole point of
profiling is doing exactly what you said
like it captures a large variety of
economic econometric models and metrics
function metrics and distributional
metrics where we can a user has the
ability to pick and choose what whatever
they want without having the need to
recompute uh recompute anything so and
also the size of the profiles are really
really small compared to the actual data
so we have never had the need to
recompute any of them
yeah thanks
any other questions
hi yes
so that's a good question
um so essentially there is a setup like
let's say this is the first day I'm
writing this system and I have to
backfill data for for a year that has
some cost of computation because you
have to build profile for a year but
going forward we basically can have a
daily job which basically builds hourly
and daily profiles it takes about 20
minutes to build the profiles and it
takes about 10 minutes or 10 to 15
minutes to basically get anomalies for
all the models across the company so
together we can think of this as a 30
minute job a day to build profiles and
find anomaly detection or do anomalies
across all the models so we're talking
about several several hundreds of models
and we're also in terms of the compute
cluster we are using spark and roughly
around 32 30 like 32 pods with like see
yeah
it's it's really uh not that much
on a daily basis yes so there was one
yeah hi
metrics that you're profiling so that
you never
there's never you made sure that your
profile is extensive
foreign
yeah like so so the sorry the question
was a follow-up on uh previously
basically is the idea that we never want
to go back to individual points yes the
idea is we don't want to actually go
back to individual data points to
go and pick on to for to do anomaly
detection on them the idea is to capture
the essence as much yeah Han wants to
add something
verify
also the example so if you really want
to look at some of the sample
if you really want to look at some of
the sample inference log you are able to
see that we do sampling
our expectation is we don't want people
to really look at the raw data or even
the sample data because that takes a lot
of time our philosophy is what is
anomaly detection anomaly detection is
not to help you find yes or no but it's
to help you to it's it's to accelerate
the process
for you to find yes or no right so this
is our design philosophy so you we
really want you to look at minimal
amount of information and to make the
quickest decision if there is any issue
or not but if you want to like do Deep
dive you want we can you can look at the
sample and if you want to get the full
data okay yeah you can just get the full
data from the roll log using SQL it is
also totally fine but think about that
how long that will take right yeah our
philosophy is if originally it took you
like two hours to investigate an issue
now one minute you should see I mean
with business with a business context as
a modeler as the owner of the model is
the business context
and when you see these charts you can
tell if there is issue or not in one
minute I think it's worth it yeah we do
not want to make the final decision for
you telling you if there is any any
issue because the notice this is the
first layer of protection it doesn't
mean we do not have other protection
actually the first layer is totally
unsupervised the second layer is totally
manual so every model owner we encourage
them to have their manual rules because
Matt what is manual rule manual rule is
the business context so the second layer
will incorporate a lot of business
context that will be more more accurate
right yeah so we we want the layered
protection for our system yeah yeah like
as a platform team we do not want to be
involved in every single team who's
building a model like we also do not
have enough context to be debugging
their models our job is to basically
Point them to a direction where there is
something wrong and it's up to
individual teams to take it up and then
investigate
um any more questions
all right thank you I'll hand it off
yeah you wanna so I'll hand it off
turning though to talk about learnings
and if you have time he can talk about
fume
thank you
hello
thanks Raji
so we have one slide I will just
quickly touch on it
can you hear me
okay yeah
so why why did we go through all these
steps like this is like merging of many
things profiling engineering merging and
then stats forecast and things like that
yeah so this so we learned that
Computing aggregated Matrix can be very
slow and cost prohibitive you all know
have been have I'm sure you have faced
these challenges and incremental
processing day by day makes it more we
we want to have a cost effective way of
doing things so this mechanism helped us
to do this
effectively and also this aggregation
Matrix after profiling gives you a clear
sign of seasonality and Cycles in the
metric of your choice
and then we later correlate like the
Delta d y the Delta of prediction with d
x the Delta of a feature drift and so
there's a
basic way of protecting the system as
Han was mentioning yeah so we are at
this stage and we will use this planning
we are working on using this
fundamental piece in like other areas
like Rajiv mentioned like real time like
as the data is streaming in if we have
the forecast from previous profile data
can we detect animal on the file
yeah so I will stop here and there is
one
quick
I I wanted to add one thing I don't know
so like we showed uh all this with
respect to in context of models machine
learning models but if you think about
this in reality this is just a
univariate Time series which is
applicable to a wide range of contexts
so for example we are even using this to
for business metric analysis for for
example operations team they have tons
and tons of univariate time data and
Reporting anomalies on that is really
really useful because they they
basically find this really useful so
that that is one one aspect so any
problem in this in a company that can be
modeled to a univariate Time series can
be applied to the solution can be
applied
um we are even applying this to
real-time anomaly detection where we ah
where we use the generated forecasts for
the next day and then when the next step
in the events are happening we actually
compare what's have what was generated
yesterday and try to report anomalies so
like these are some of the uh
interesting things that can be done
yeah thanks Rajiv and while we are
talking so if some of you have been
careful observed that I ran some three
cells what was that so we talk about
like scaling up using spark Ray or desk
so here is an example I just changed I
just took the first notebook and just
changed the engine to desk it is an
example how Fugue transform can use disk
on a notebook which is running on a
Docker engine to distribute the
parallelism I I can see at least there
are three repetitions of this block so
three processes spinning up under the
hood and it is using disk to split the
data into partitions and it is still
Computing it will take one minute and if
you are careful this cell errored out at
some point of time ah if a live demo
doesn't have an error then it does not
make a demo worth so so that's what
happened so I fixed it and it will run
it in one minute so yeah we can take
more questions this is our end of the
demo and we can take additional
questions
do you install Fugue in your ecosystem
say AWS or whatever other Google or any
other ecosystem you're in yeah it's a
it's a great question actually it it
digresses into a different topic but
it's a great question so we usually use
spark most of our processing is on spark
so we have custom spark image for us so
where that Docker image contains spark
as well as Fugue as well as other
libraries along with it so when we spawn
the spark executors and we had a talk
last databricks AI Summit how we use
spark on kubernetes but the tldr is we
have many executors these each of the
executors is based on a custom image
which has few
mstl the stats forecast everything
installed in each of these so that they
can process each of these data yeah so
the task has also completed as we as we
speak
thank you
any other questions
okay all right thank you folks for
coming in and the codes are already
public and let us know if you want to
chat more about it
we are here
we can be oh
all right thank you
[Applause]